my super Europe project was lipid
suppression techniques for magnetic
resonance spectroscopy imaging in
infants now I'm working on a project
focused on the acoustic analysis of
speech my project is to enable data
visualization for mobile humanitarian
technologies we're trying to instrument
several different types of wheelchairs
with sensors in order to get long-term
usage patterns across different
countries I'm working on personalizing
text recommendations for foreign
language earnings I'm really interested
in green technology we thought we could
build this robot to to kind of take the
place of first responders and like save
lives essentially using radar in an
unknown environment is a highly
unconstrained problem so we decided to
go with a machine learning approach
namely neural nets we're using
accelerometers or using strain gauges
and we saw that there was lipid signal
contamination I am about halfway done
with my first prototype so that's
exciting one thing I really enjoyed us
like the kind of bona fide research
experience that I had with my mentor so
like every day we'd sit down and talk
about the problem for papers I've read
and like try to develop more on these
protocols that we worked on I just
wanted to do good rigorous technical
research it's given me complete freedom
of implementation it's a very beautiful
application of physics I've learned so
much about like the actual process like
a research I know what you have to do to
communicate your research and your ideas
when I found this project that had a
chance to make a real impact on people's
daily lives I really wanted to work on
it and make a difference
I'm very invested in the project because
it's my own it kind of like reenergized
me like this is why I came to MIT people
are working on these impossible things
and doing amazing work